Bekka creating cultivate I mean you
already did your panel how'd it go it
went really well
I it was kind of walked out and there
were so many people there and then I was
on the bossing up panel so I was with
legit people with these legit companies
and now it's kind of like I'm honored to
be here with this game you are a boss
though you know why do you feel that way
I am I'm making my way towards that like
my goal is to be up there and for
someone like me to be like I can't
believe I'm with Becca Tilly
the founder of blank gbb I mean when you
think about the Becca Empire like what
does that look like what do you want to
have I want to have I want to be an
executive producer of it like TV or
digital series I want to have my own
beauty product I want our podcast to
blow up so doing amazing things um wait
you want to produce a series oh yeah I
want to create a series I've rethought
that what you pitched what I pitched a
series I don't think I can talk about it
yet
just because doesn't gone anywhere yet
but um just kind of a fun series of just
incorporating me with a friend or
someone maybe from bachelor nation like
an ashley i or around i got no i nail
that what i mean if people could take
away one thing from this boss panel what
is that what's the messaging you know I
might have whole things that one of the
advice at all one of the pieces of
advice that I always give is to ask for
help and there's so many people like
there are some big names here with some
big companies and I guarantee if you
went up to any of them and asked for
advice on how to incorporate something
that they've done into your career what
you're wanting to do they would answer
you and that's one of the coolest things
is that so everyone's so willing to
share
no one's stingy with their advice
because everyone's kind of looking out
for each other which is not what you'd
expect being in this industry but
everyone is that way so I would just say
ask for help and be like I don't know
what I'm doing I mean I kind of do feel
like you said we wouldn't expect it but
I do feel like we're getting to a place
for women
supporting women so much more I mean do
you feel like there's more work to be
done especially kind of coming from
bachelor nation where we do see some
cattiness in the world still or what how
do you feel about all that there's a
little cattiness this season yeah I
think there's always work to be done and
everything I mean you think of all the
issues and the progress that we've made
but there's still a lot of work to go so
I think we have made a lot of progress
and I think people are a lot more
willing to help each other out then
maybe they were in the past or even a
few years ago because of being
competitive but um yeah there's always
progress to be made I think if we get to
a place where we feel like we have like
hit the top and we're all little unaware
um we do have to talk a little bit of
bachelor yeah do you know what went down
at the women tell all like have you
heard anything no do you know I want to
know the tyranny yeah the only thing I
saw was that um Kelly wasn't invited she
wasn't invited when she was in the top
five I don't know if that's ever
happened she posted someone messaged her
and I guess she said they said well you
be at the Women's Hall and she said
something along the lines of I wasn't
invited so I don't know what happened
but I loved her that's weird to me that
she wouldn't be yeah I think a lot of
people liked her right and like but then
Victoria got to go well yeah I mean not
everyone's gonna be watching for
Victoria uh who do you think should win
it's weird that it hasn't been spoiled
for us yet do you have a front-runner do
you have any inclination about what
could happen here's my here's what I
think I the problem is that I really
like Maddie but I don't know if I want
her with Peter for her to be the
Bachelorette from of girls from this
season so I'm torn but I have a theory
of what happens but I think it's kind of
the basic one that's going around
or that he proposes to Maddie and I
think that Maddie leaves before the
proposal day because she finds out that
he slipped her was intimate with the
other I don't know I'm people thanks I'm
like the most into this season of trying
to figure out the spoilers like the not
knowing is bothering me usually like you
do know and we have all those like like
you don't like when I do these
interviews and they're like so who do
you think is gonna win in the whole time
I'm like I know who won so I don't think
people did want Hannah Brown to be the
Bachelorette again you oh you do yeah I
love - Hannah season she was one of my
favorite seasons of The Bachelorette and
I feel like she surprised a lot of
people I found it to be entertaining my
only thing would be like would the guys
be there just because Hannah has this
fame you know that's a whole nother
question because don't you think and let
me know if I'm wrong but people are
starting to go on because of the
influence that maybe they could gain do
you think that that's a real thing or do
you think people really go on to find
love at this point I don't know what
people's our intentions are I am so glad
that I was on this season kind of right
before the social media influencing took
off because it would have been hard to
not have that thought in the back here
of mine when you see these people from
the show like traveling all over the
world and having these brand deals and
moving to LA it would be so tempting to
go on knowing that that could be the
result but I don't know I don't know do
you think there should be a better
vetting process for that kind of stuff
because we all know a lot of them are
influencers when they even come on the
show to begin with yeah I would create
if I were going on now and I had
intentions of just being an influencer I
create a fake profile maybe have like
120 followers so that they would be like
oh she has no intention other than love
you would trick the system I do what I
have to do luckily I didn't have to do
that or even think about that what do
you think though I mean every season it
feels like there's more controversy
there's a contestant with like stories
that are coming out do you think the
bachelor producers find this stuff out
and put them on anyways
or do you think they don't do a good job
of learning maybe some of the person's
history they did so many interviews and
testing and like they went asked us if
there was anything in our past so I
don't know what's going on but I've
noticed it's happening a lot more these
days but I don't know if it just
provides more drama and more talk about
the show so they're kind of like you
know any press is good press but I don't
know I'm in it I'm like too in it I was
never in it until you really this season
I know I'm really into it like real
bachelor nation here which is do you
like being part of that like do you like
being associated with Bachelor yeah of
course I mean I want him I wouldn't be
doing anything I'm doing without The
Bachelor you know I'm very grateful for
it and it's cool I've I feel like I'm
separated enough where I can talk about
it and have fun and not feel like I'm so
in it still that I don't have anything
else going on but um yeah I'll always
think The Bachelor it's why I'm at how
much Bachelor is too much Bachelor
though because there's like spin-offs
and more spin-offs and I feel like it's
all year-round now do you think do you
think there's such thing as too much
Bachelor I mean listen I just only have
so many hours in a day and a week and
I'm I'm like I have to sit down and
watch The Bachelor whether it's what's
the listen to your heart what's the
other summer games I wish they would do
summer games with like and it wasn't so
much focused around dating which I guess
I want to be the bachelor but that's oh
yeah more emphasis on yeah but listen as
much as I complain about too much
Bachelor I will be sitting on my couch
watching every single episode could you
ever go back would you ever want to go
back and do oh no I think I'm I wish I'm
retired
you're retired from The Bachelor okay
before I let you go do you think Peter
is ready to settle down with somebody
after watching maybe what he's gone
through I think he's probably shocked
watching it back at like how some of the
girls acted towards each other but I
think he's ready I just don't know if
the girls are like I feel I kind of feel
bad for Peter Som
I was because I feel like he's in a
place where he's kind of frustrated cuz
he's really looking for it and he's
having to deal with a lot of drama but
he seems like a great guy I hope that he
finds someone that is on the same page
as him who do you want so you want
Maddie to be the Bachelorette maybe is
there anyone else they would like to see
if it's not Hannah probably can't be
Hannah cuz she's gonna be on tour um oh
there's this girl that went home really
early on her name's Sarah coffin pop I'm
so upset that she went home so early
it was beautiful not I'm not saying
beauty's everything but we didn't get to
know her personality but I follow her on
Instagram we DM she's really nice so I
don't know what could be wrong with her
oh yeah why did she get sent home do you
think did she talk to you about it or
you don't know and we haven't gotten no
we're not that close you or diem hey but
if they would just bring someone random
I'd be so happy for it to be her I kind
of think it's time for them to break the
cycle and maybe do someone and she has
like a good enough following at this
point just because people were like what
happened why did you go home so early so
I think people would be interested in
her Sarah Kaufman bachelor you heard it
here first it's Becca Chile's pick
[Music]